in some places it's visible and vile
this was shot on thursday raw sewage
pumped into landstone harbour in
hampshire non-stop for 49 hours
countrywide anger is swelling in seaford
there weren't many braving the water the
bracing wind perhaps but there could be
another reason too how does it make you
feel to know that they literally did a
dump here in the last 24 hours yeah
that's disgusting that's not good yeah i
don't feel great about that i'll be
having a bath when i get home
sewage dumps are a vestige of our
victorian sewage system where rainwater
and wastewater are released together
when the system gets too full southern
water alone has done it nearly 3 000
times since july
just up the coast libby and her friends
have had enough she's now testing the
water she's swam in for years there's e
coli here she says and it's getting
worse
there's wet wipes there's sanitary
towels there's tampons
we've had swimmers reporting swimming
along and having a sanitary towel stick
to their face the government had a
chance to vote through an amendment to
do something about this and they didn't
how did that make you feel they've
completely and utterly
an amazing opportunity to act and to do
something good for
climate change for for nature
for
the population
but perhaps not for long the government
ultimately pushed to respond to the rage
thousands took to social media to call
out mps who last week voted against
legal duties for companies that
discharged sewage
it prompted new policy a promise to
enshrine into law requirements that the
practice declines this government's done
way more than any government uh in
recent decades to address the problem
but now we're saying we're going to go a
step further and and we've listened to
the debate that took place in parliament
so we will write what is already
government policy into
the statutes to give people that
reassurance they seek
it may not prove enough for some who say
major investment in the system is the
only real answer martus campaigned
against discharge into lake windermere
if we can save our wildlife and save our
environment then it's you know it's
money well spent you know if they do it
now then it means that in the future
they're going to have to spend less
money on solving this issue they can't
ignore it you know people are outraged
by it 104 000 people have signed my
petition you know change has to happen
now a major overhaul of the sewage
system will cost hundreds of billions of
pounds the government's now assessing
just how much discharge into open water
does prevent sewage backlogs coming up
into the streets but for those who swim
sail or simply enjoy the sea neither is
acceptable
helen smith sky news seaford